the three-ball deal no good loose ball
hole look out again and another leak got
room to save us
porker punching at home now that's the
way to send it down when you're a big
guy and you have the opportunity to
gather yourself wonder what are they
doing what where's the game plan where's
the power game get into the paint walls
of that in the paint
oh no kid is in wall does know that in
the paint
oh no kid is in might heard you coach
now I'm and if I other end Bradley gets
another quick one on the leak out and
where somebody is hitting the snooze bar
and let's face it because Bradley peel
is on Isaiah Tom here's Beal another one
on the way and maybe that gets him going
consecutive buckets ill over Crowder
from downtown and one of 15 from deep
wall gonna try a three balls and John
Wall coming to life in the third quarter
go
sadly off to Johnson spring found the
screener and got a layup out of it well
that's because Breitling was opened as a
game for Amir Johnson spheal got in the
paint
Bose glass to tie the game at 50 G to
paint and that was just reading the
defense perfectly his reap Radley behind
the Horford screen and Avery Bradley
getting back in that rhythm that saw him
score 29 in Game five
Indians contributed already in the
ballgame Thomas / Morris a high arcing
jumper it's nothing but net and there
Johnson clears bad angle Thomas in
transition finds Crowder for what a time
that was great pass to the layout big
Crowder now with 8 Thomas was the last
pick folks last pick in the second round
back in 2010
as Brad Beal gets the layup for
Washington at the other end with Honda
tech and watch it it takes possession
feel the two-on-one for the slam brake
pads
he's reset on the shot clock the 14 on
the file Norfolk straight away three is
good he continues to sizzle from
downtown to back finish the number four
seed in the East feel on the baseline
gotta pretty not only did he beat his
man smart back out to Horford
debrie Bradley boy he has been a
different player offensively Hubie since
game bot another quarter to go but you
like his back that he stood for three
with the three ball and doing it at the
defensive end
although wall got the better of him at
that time on the drive
crowd organize showings Oh step-back
three is Jonah day for Isaiah Thomas
sick with the clock down fractured three
other so he said he now has a mouthful
of fake keep a good luck
[Applause]
and John Wall was spinning like a top
this is down inside also not that far
away from the basket right around
Olynyk right there how about that move
three on the clock had to fire Morris
with the ticket for a play great
employee by Mars while getting such a
tick back into the ball game for Scott
Brooks feel guarded by Bradley little
contact for Beal finishes through it now
that was a great whole season long the
number to fourth quarter score in the
lead and Beal finds it again he's making
it happen now they're smart
every brad.leah cheap three men he's
shooting with so much confidence Avery
Bradley all mix it out to feel feel
underneath man how did he make that one
that's the third one the third one from
the corner the baseline screen as well
as McDonald wall with the pull-up he's
been a different guy folks here in the
second half for 18 now all the
difference in his game changing speeds
you got a boyfriend oh do it to each
other and watch this move here now
remember he's doing that to a guy at 6/8
and you don't even notice him getting
him and how many heat slaps out set a
good screen for Beal and Bale drops the
J in seven potentially would be Monday
wall inside yes
Crowder was there to block that shot
downtown Horford with a quick rebound
Thomas and open three yes great filet
Parker two of the Wizards 38 points here
in the second half Morris trying to
contribute part of three with water
heroics in store here tonight working
against Beal off the screen Morris picks
them up
and Isaiah Thomas it's nothing but net
Soviets leading by two about it's
incredible at five foot nine how he has
the ability to shoot launching another
three he does it again and you know what
time it is by now 50% and then go to the
ballon and make his foul shots under
pressure 82 games and now in the
playoffs they rely on him so much in the
fourth quarter where there's your heart
drop and they turn him over this time
yeah there was no outlet since there
were no green shirts movement for the
outlet field finally his first three of
the ballgame Boston wins tonight they
take on Cleveland Bradley here's the
long - actually they're calling it along
to run off the three-point line by
Olynyk as a mismatch takes advantage on
we're tied at 18
time shot big-time shot Thomas comes
around to get it on the move back to
Horford little pick and pop he used love
and they lead by two with seven point
seven a play butter can't find anybody
he gives it to all market gets Bradley
for three
[Applause]
you talk about a precious shot that was
it
every Bradley I got a little something
for you here
now your Boston you have three and a
half seconds Crowder and bounding for
the Celtics Thomas got the catch three
on the way for the win for Game seven
[Applause]
[Music]